Hey everybody welcome to "The Podcast."
So today's gonna be a little bit different.
As some of you may know, I spent the week
of April 13 in Minneapolis a very tense Minneapolis.
And I think it's fair to say
that it was a rather historic
and personally very moving week
in which the eyes of the world
were witness to both the death of Daunte Wright?
And the tail end of the Derek Chauvin trial.
I was there through the end of the defense's case
but home by the time the verdict was delivered.
And essentially what all of these events mean,
what they portend not just for
the current and future of Minneapolis
but for the civil rights movement
the broader relationship between government power in general
and citizenship and our country at large.
The reason for this trip, the intention,
the goal really was to better understand the circumstances
that led to consume this city.
And in many ways, the nation,
not from what I read
or saw streaming endlessly on cable news
but rather from a firsthand perspective,
a sort of boots on the ground experience.
And at the same time to conduct
meaningful nuanced conversations with civic leaders
in Minneapolis about the important issues
that the city and its citizens are currently grappling
with from police misconduct
and public safety reform to civil unrest.
And of course, the role that social activism
has played in all of this.
This conversation, the first and what will be
a series of Minneapolis themed episodes
that I'll be releasing over the coming weeks
is with Jeremiah Ellison who represents ward five
on the Minneapolis City Council.
As both an activist and an elected official
Jeremiah's sits at the vortex
of many of the complicated issues that concern his community
and is somebody who from the start
has been one of the leading and most prominent voices
calling for the re-imagination of like safety.
This guy at heart is really an artist.
He's a muralist, a street and comic book artist.
And so for that reason he sort of makes
for a very unlikely politician.
But at the same time he's also the son
of six term Congressman Keith Ellison
who is now the attorney general for the State of Minnesota.
And in that capacity led the Chauvin prosecution.
So you can also make the argument
that Jeremiah was a guy who was actually born
for the role he currently inhabits.
My week in Minneapolis was extraordinary.
There are so many experiences that I will never forget.
I learned a ton and I'll be sharing much more
about all of that on the next roll-on episode
later this week and other content
that we're currently working on and I'm better the trip
and Jeremiah has a lot to do with that.
I'm grateful that he took the time to share his truth
and for his trust in my ability
to share it with all of you
and the result of our time spent together
produced what I believe to be a rather powerful exchange.
So please welcome him and his testimony
with an open mind and an open heart.
And here we go, this is me and Jeremiah Ellison.
Once again, man, I appreciate you doing this.
Yeah I appreciate the invite.
It's almost nine o'clock at night.
(all laughing)
Usually I do these at like noon.
I'm just waking up.
I know, I hope my energy.
I can keep it going,
but the reason we're doing it at night
is because we're well Ramadan just kicked off
so you're fascinating.
So you just broke your fast,
the meal, what's the meal called?
Iftar yeah.
Iftar right, yeah.
So I broke fast just real quickly.
'Cause I knew I needed to make it over here,
but like, yeah two dates, two oranges,
like half a gallon of water.
(all laughing)
That's not, yeah, 'cause you can't drink,
you don't drink water.
Yeah like I'll have like,
the I'll go home and I'll eat again after this.
But like, I'm like I can't like cook right now.
You have like a big food coma right,
before you come over here too.
Have you been doing that your whole life?
Yeah, I can't remember how young I was when I started
you know, I wasn't five, like some,
you know some kids in the faith,
they like we'll
start that young.
Right.
I don't think I was that young
but definitely like middle school, high school.
Right, it's cool, man.
I like the tradition,
part of the tradition is well it's about
is it not about kind of self-reflection like introspection.
Yeah, like humility.
Like restraint.
Humility which are all interesting
kind of states of mind
as we're in this crazy moment here in your city.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, you know the I feel like for a long time,
Ramadan for me was just fasting.
Like it was just the hungry you get when you're young
especially you're gonna fixate on the not eating part
'cause you're not eating, it sucks
you know for a whole month.
And you know, somewhere in my early 20s
I had like a I don't know how to describe it,
but like the end of Ramadan,
like I just felt something different.
Like I just felt like I was taking it on differently.
It was no longer just about like an exercise
of like you know, you know,
this you can turn fasting into a sport, right.
Like, can I get through the day?
Right.
Yeah.
And so yeah, the humility,
you know, fasting from from anger
and some of these intangible things
are like really become the goal.
They really become the focus for me.
And the food part is like it helps,
you know it helps direct and direct that,
but it's the point.
Right, you're purging,
you're detoxifying yourself
of these negative emotional states.
And it's a spiritual,
you know sort of journey that you go on for a month.
Right, that kind of squarely places you
in a deeper connection with yourself.
Yeah, for sure and it's communal,
you know like it's not eating can feel deeply individual.
Yeah.
You know but the practices communal,
you got millions of people all over the world
but then even more immediately,
you know that you've got like neighbors down the street,
like there's a mosque on the other side
of the block from where I live.
It's not the one I go to,
but you know it's always kind of fun to see like.
Right.
You know folks
gathering together to break fast.
Do iftar together, some people spent all night
you know and the mosque you know praying
and it can be pretty cool.
And what happens so like May 15th is the end, right.
So what happens when you finally conclude it?
Yeah I mean, usually I don't know what we'll do.
I did get my second vaccine shot,
so I'll have to see where family's at.
And if everyone in the family's got my sister's gotten it,
my brother's a nurse, so he's gotten it.
So I think most of us are might be fully vaccinated by Eid.
And so hopefully.
Yeah.
We can do, right.
So.
Well you have
a fascinating story.
The more I kind of dive into everything that you're about
the more interested I become
and you're a bit of a conundrum
because on the one hand
you're just such an unlikely politician.
Like you're a street artist, you're comic book artists.
I wanna see your comic book art.
You didn't bring any comics did you.
No, I didn't bring me anything you know.
So on that level, like how does this make sense?
And yet as the son of your father Keith,
six term Congressman now attorney general
and kind of leading the prosecutorial team
and the Chauvin trial,
it's like, of course you're doing this.
It's like you're following in your father's footsteps
in your own unique way,
bringing your own kind of imprimatur
to what it is that you do.
But how do you think about this?
It's like, you didn't show up in a tie
you know, you got a beanie on you rocking the tats.
(all laughing)
You're a man of the people,
but you're first and foremost an artist.
Yeah, I like to think so,
you know I have been painting and drawing my entire life.
You know, if my dad were here he would talk about,
you know that my parents trying to figure out
how to channel my artistic impulses
'cause, you know, we I grew up in this old house
and the wallpaper would peel back.
And so I was just like the kid
that's like, "Okay, I'm gonna peel the wallpaper back
"draw something little and put it back up."
But I feel like the way that I came into art
and my practice in general, especially mural painting
you know, it really connects,
it really overlaps with the way that I govern
and really important way.
Now I'll say this quick story
but when I was eight years old,
I got involved with this organization
called Juxtaposition Arts and Roger Cummings
and Peyton Russell were my art instructors back then.
And I show up to the first day of mural painting
eight years old, I'm really excited.
The next youngest person was 14.
Yeah.
So I'm
the youngest person there.
I'm really excited to paint this mural.
I'm thinking, "Okay I'm gonna get my hand on a spray can."
They had spent all winter making me do still lives
you know, so I could do the (indistinct) get to the basics.
And I'm like, "Now I wanna be graffiti artists."
And so I show up and I'm ready to paint.
And Roger's like, hands me a notepad and a pen.
And he's like, "Okay I want you
"to walk three blocks that way
"and walk three blocks in the opposite direction.
"And everybody you talk to who lives in the area.
"I don't care what they're doing.
"Just ask them what kind of thing
"they wanna see on the wall.
"That doesn't mean we're necessarily gonna paint it."
But you know, when you are gonna make public art
you've gotta engage the public.
That's the lesson.
Yeah.
I was learning that at eight,
you know, I think every mural process I ever had
incorporated some kind of community feedback.
And even once you started painting,
you know, I especially I remember when I would get older,
people would walk by and they would say like,
you know, that's whack.
Like I don't like how that looks, you know?
Or they would say, "Hey, I'm interested
"to see how you finis."
Or they'd give you compliments.
Like the community engages,
especially on the North side of Minneapolis,
the community's gonna engage
they're gonna tell you if they don't like it.
Right.
Gonna tell you
if they like it.
And really what they're telling you
is an roundabout way,
is whether or not you engage them so.
Yeah, that's a huge life skill
and a cornerstone of being an effective politician, right?
You have to go into the community,
meet these people, meet them where they're at
and try to develop some consensus around your vision.
Like, you might think this is what I wanna do.
They don't want it,
how much are you willing to bend and compromise?
How can you get them on board with what you wanna do?
Like all of these are the skills that come into play
every minute of your day.
Yeah.
Now I would imagine.
Yeah no, absolutely.
And outreach can be tough,
especially as a local elected,
you're battling, you know the fact that,
especially in my seat,
there's this legacy of not engaging with folks.
And so that means that, you know,
the level of people who think to call their council member
when they're having an issue is relatively low.
And so I go to try to, you know turn that up.
I want people, you know might be a little bit weird
but I want people complaining to my office, right?
Like that's how I'm gonna be effective in my role
but it can be tough right.
To get that level of input.
I think we've done a pretty good job so far.
And you're absolutely right
sometimes people aren't quite there with you, right.
They're not seeing what you're seeing
and that does present its own kind of like question, right.
You can't leave your constituents behind
it's just not, it's not the right thing to do
but you also can't just say,
"Do the wrong thing, make the wrong decision
"because you think it will be unpopular
"with your constituents."
And that's where you kind of create
that that where you have that tension, right?
Yeah well globally,
or kind of at a macro context
people are so, you know, kind of,
you know, disabused of any idea
that their politicians have their interest at heart,
you know, they're bought and paid for
by special interest groups
and they're just looking to get reelected
and they're gonna pander to their base.
And anything else is just a mirror distraction
beyond fundraising, right.
But you're a guy who kind of was foisted
into the public eye by dent of the activist work
that you did in particular that one kind
of viral photograph of you with your hands up
and the rifle in your face
from the cops that was.
Shamar.
Shamar right, sorry in like 2015, right.
Yep.
So this kind of, you know,
becomes not really a calling card,
but it becomes kind of emblazoned on people's minds
that you're a man of the people, right?
Yeah.
But then as you become an elected official
there's a blurring line between activism
and kind of effecting responsible political change.
Right, like I'm interested in like how that works.
Like where does the activist end,
and where does the elected official begin
to those things kind of merged together?
Or do you have to think of them as like separate identities?
I think you have to be honest with yourself
about what this job can do to people
even if they have good intentions, right.
And if you're honest about which to be clear
I think usually when, from my experience
when folks are maybe being called like a sellout,
right like that term
or that process of going from being,
you know, okay I came in with all these ideals
and you know maybe I'm a little bit,
I've moved into this other category
where people aren't really feeling me.
I think that that happens
because of exhaustion and it happens to people
because they think it can't happen to them, you know?
And so for me, it's about keeping perspective
and not taking some of that,
some of that anger that people might have towards me,
constituents or activists or whoever.
Not taking it personal, because I know that
there have been people, whether in my immediate seat
or just in elected office before
who have earned a lot of the bad will
that people have for politicians,
right?
Yeah.
So you have to double down on the transparency
and the outreach and the boots on the ground,
in the community.
And I think that you also have to,
in a way, figure out how to be vulnerable,
how, you know, it's not a quality
that's rewarded in this position.
Right, and there are ways to be sort of fully vulnerable
right like I don't know, crying in public.
Right.
And there are ways.
Performative on social media, yeah oversharing.
Yeah absolutely.
And then there are ways where to be vulnerable
that can earn some good trust and that are real
may not look vulnerable on their face, right.
You know, there have been times
where I have thought something was needed in my community.
Like a couple of months ago I was advocating
for a women's homeless shelter
and the neighbors were like,
"Council member,
"hell no we don't want a homeless shelter here."
And you know ultimately, you know I was,
I it didn't prevail as much as I wanted it to.
I had public meetings where I was just,
Oh my God, I was just blasted at these meetings.
Not in my backyard kind of thing.
Yeah, and people with some legitimate fear
right, like I think people have been fed
a lot of gross narratives about homeless people
and it's not my job to judge them
for having consumed those messages
but it is my job to maybe do some political education
and try to help them unlearn some of those messages.
And so when I'm looking at somebody
who's using criminalizing language for homeless people,
I disagree with them.
I gotta work to make sure that I'm winning and not them,
Yeah.
But I don't judge them,
right, I don't dismiss them
because I know in some ways like what they want
and what I want and what that person who's living
out on the street wants is probably pretty similar.
They've just got it, they walked into the conversation
with a lot of preconceived notions.
Now, some of the people who were standing against me
in that meeting, I thought you know
I've lost this person support, right.
Not only did I lose this person support,
I also you know, some of the other electeds
who were in the room where looked around
saw me getting yelled at and thought,
"Oh, I'm not gonna support it
"'cause I don't wanna be in his position."
Yeah.
And then we end up loosing.
That shelter didn't get bill.
And so, and so it's kind of a setback
but you've got folks who stood against it at the time
who have reached back out to say,
"You know actually I see what you were doing there."
You have folks who are in the back of the crowd,
maybe seeing me get heckled.
And you know, they're just everyday people.
They don't wanna be heckled themselves
but they agreed with me.
And those are the kinds of things
that can happen when you're willing to,
you know go out on a limb when you're not operating
in that mode of, "What's gonna get me liked in this moment."
Right so you're your district is ward five
it's 82% people of color yeah.
And something like 40% of the population
is below the poverty line.
Yeah.
So this is the, you know,
kind of modus from which you're operating
and the people on behalf of whom you're advocating for.
It's interesting that even then,
there's blind spots like
you're trying to champion the underdog
but these other underdogs are like,
"Hey, what about me?"
Yeah.
Like, it just gets complicated.
It does get complicated.
I think that's why, you know
I think that's why that,
like the only term I can think of is political Ed,
like political education is just really important.
It can't happen if you're dismissing people,
it can't happen if you're condescending people,
people are pretty smart,
but they are also a lot of things on top of that.
Right people might be afraid at any given moment.
People might have not wrestled with their biases.
Right, all these things can occur.
And so, you know I think that's how,
you can find yourself in a position like that.
And I know for some of those folks,
they thought, they're thinking,
well, yeah I'm poor right.
And this guy, you know meaning me,
wants to "dump more poor people in my neighborhood"
And eliminate amount of resources
into a program that doesn't benefit my life.
Right.
Yeah.
And you know, it's a scarcity mindset.
You know, my mindset is, you know
you're greeted when you arrive
you're given what you're needed, right.
And I'm always gonna have that attitude.
And so I'll continue to make sure,
you know make sure that we're doing our fair share
in building shelters,
but you know, I can I can disagree
while empathizing with someone who might be advocating
for a position that I can't stand on.
Yeah well, that's your job right.
You're constantly dealing with people
that don't see things that you do, right.
I mean, you're like in the shit right now
like you're in the cross hairs
the entire world is paying attention
to what's happening in Minneapolis right now.
I would imagine that that must feel
at times burdensome to carry that kind of level
of responsibility and you know,
on the subject of political education
and boots on the ground.
I mean, that's my motivation in coming here.
Like everybody else I've been watching
what's been going on here over the last year.
This feels like a very important historic moment.
We're at a sort of crossroads,
I think with what's going on in the city
and there's what's gonna happen with the verdict
and how is Minneapolis gonna move forward or not from this.
But I think also because everybody's paying
such close attention
the ripple effect in terms of like how we're gonna function
as a nation and even across the world,
I think has profound implications, right.
And I just wanted to share with you yesterday,
you know as somebody who thought
they were paying fairly close attention
to what was happening here, I haven't been here before.
I mean, the last time I visited Minneapolis I was a kid
and we went to George Floyd square yesterday.
And in my mind as like this progressive,
you know conscious citizen, I thought I knew what to expect.
And it defied all of that.
Like all of that went out the window
as soon as I arrived there.
And it was nothing like what I thought it would be
from the setting to the neighborhood
to the visceral experience
of being in what is really a living, breathing
not just Memorial, but museum grieving place,
gathering spot.
Like it's so many things you can't define it
as any one thing.
And I was not expecting to be as moved as I was by it
or as welcomed as I was.
We had a great encounter with the Agape folks.
You know, that group
who then, we'd spent like an hour there
and then we were getting ready to leave.
And they're like, "Hey, what are you guys doing?"
And then they ended up like giving us a VIP tour.
And it was incredible, man.
And you know, I had a hard time sleeping last night.
I was so moved by it.
And what it did beyond just that experience
in of itself was remind me of not just my own biases,
but how when I think I know something,
I really don't know,
like there's always room to expand and to grow and to learn.
And I left that realizing
how little I actually was connected
to what was happening here and just kind of,
there's something about the heaviness of it all.
Like, you can feel the emotion
of everybody that's in that space.
And so I don't know if this is leading to a question
it's more like an observation.
Yeah.
Like the context in which I'm coming to you today
as somebody who, you know, is grappling
in the political sphere with these issues,
how do you you know, think about how you communicate,
you know when you go on Chris Hayes or CBS News
and all these kinds of things that you've been doing lately.
I think that we have these kind of preset narratives
about a place about people.
And, you know we have that in policy
and politics as well, right?
You either, I think a lot of folks have tried to
squeeze this conversation into like.
You either think that people safety is a priority
and you want more police
or you think we live in a utopia
and you don't think we need police, right?
Like, that's been the binary of this conversation
when like that's not the truth.
And I you know, I don't fault people.
It is incredibly difficult to tell the truth
when you have these preset narratives
and the truth isn't fitting into any of them.
You know, people feel like you're not really making sense.
My whole goal, especially in this moment
is to make sure that I'm telling the truth, right?
And the truth is that we do need to have a conversation
about how we keep each other safe,
as neighbors, as you know residents.
And that the police is not the only
are not the only means for which we can do that.
You can have both conversations.
You can acknowledge that keeping people safe is a priority
without having to sort of dive into
these preset narratives about.
Right here we go again,
we're gonna do the same thing we've always done.
And we're always getting the same result.
Absolutely.
And that's like
The definition of insanity.
So today we, you know there's just so people understand
like we're in downtown Minneapolis right now
National Guards everywhere
MVs all over the place.
Yeah.
You know, guys in uniform,
that alarm went off twice, I don't know what that was about.
It's like a pre, is a preset like.
Like it was a scheduled works or whatever.
Yeah, which is fine.
'Cause it goes off like
we're used to like,
it goes off every like first Wednesday or whatever,
but this one was also a test I was told
but it's obviously it's not Wednesday.
So a lot of people were like, what is going on?
Right.
Yeah.
I think to your point about George Floyd Square
that if you are.
Somebody else from out of town told me
that they were just surprised
by how residential and low to the ground,
the whole space was cause when you look at the pictures.
I imagined like more, a much more urban place.
Lots of stores, lots of foot traffic.
Yeah.
Was like it's not a suburb,
but it's not really the city either.
Yes.
And actually there's
a lot of nice houses around there.
Yeah.
Was nothing like what I had envisioned in my mind.
And I was walking around believing that
what I believed was true for no reason at all
because all I had seen were images
or quick little video clips
even the iconic mural,
I was like wow, it's so small.
It's just like,
(Jeremiah laughing)
I was like I thought it was like
you know four stories high or something.
Yeah, no it's, you know like
it's much more grounded, loaded
you know it's not this large scale,
you know there is,
you know I think that community members
that I've talked to will tell you, like,
yeah there's there's always been an element of like,
you know violent crime in this area.
Right, well before the barricades that certainly existed.
I have heard that story
isn't as well told as it should be.
It's all about kind of what happened
you know, last year and over the last couple months
Locally, I think that there is tried to be a narrative.
There has there have been a few who have tried to
push this narrative that they're like
the place is overrunning with
just like it's just rampant violence every day.
It's all despair you know, that's been the narrative
because there are folks who wanna remove the barricades.
And I'm not saying we can't have a conversation about
whether or not we moved the barricades.
I represent that area,
it's virtually on the opposite side of town
from where I represent.
But I do think that it simplifies sort of this narrative.
Right it's either, you know it's either a healing space
or it's hell on earth.
Right.
And the truth is that
like it's neither and we should probably
be deferring to the people who are there every day
and not just sort of creating a little echo chamber
of people who are telling us what we wanna hear.
Right, like I can't just go down there.
I'm inclined to listen to the activist
and the folks who are sleeping out there.
Right.
I can't ignore the businesses who are saying,
"Hey, this is hard for us."
Right.
But you also can't go down there,
talk to the businesses who are saying,
"Hey, this is hard for us."
And ignore all the people who have said,
"Hey, this is a space where we feel like we can,
"you know access some of our power."
Yeah.
Like I think
that you've gotta be able to hold so multiple truths.
And I think that leaders in the state
have really struggled to hold.
Yeah for people that don't know
the square is like,
I don't know it's essentially
like a little bit more than a city block.
And within the parameters of George Floyd Square
are businesses that are closed down right now.
Yeah.
So obviously those business owners
would like to reopen
the community would prefer that they don't.
And everybody's got a valid point of view on that
and it's super sensitive.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, and there's even some of the businesses
within there, I'm not gonna remember the name
but there's a woman who has,
like I had like a hair and nail place
and she's like, it's fine.
Right.
But you've got folks who have food services
and it's a little harder to move your food, right.
Like it's, you know so it's.
But Cup Foods that's like the one thing that's open.
(all laughing)
Right.
Oh my God, yeah.
Cup it's one of the,
it's high level of resilience.
Yeah.
And, you know Cornerstore is like it,
you know I kind of have a weird like,
you know appreciation for those kinds of spots.
I grew up like mostly gonna corner stores.
You know, we've got this,
you know people call it a food desert.
I think, you know I've heard the term food apartheid.
I think that's probably more appropriate.
Yeah.
In North Minneapolis as well.
And, you know as much as these corner stores,
their ownership, the way they operate,
it can be problematic.
But also they occupy space
and provide fresh, you know, food,
you know at least the option for fresh food
in places where you know, grocery stores
have largely abandoned.
Yeah there's no grocery stores.
Yeah.
And that drives
it just creates a vicious cycle
because that feeds the, you know,
the lack of health and the community
that then of course leads to all these lifestyle diseases
that make you, you know susceptible to everything
from COVID the diabetes to heart disease.
So, I mean you see George Floyd,
Guy was like jacked, you know looked fit,
but autopsy revealed that he had a heart disease.
He had pretty bad heart disease at the same time too.
So that I look at that and I'm like,
well that's purely a function of food apartheid,
you know and living in a,
you know, coming up in a space like that.
Yeah.
So it's April 15th today.
And the defense rested its case in the Chauvin trial.
Monday there's gonna be closing arguments.
It's gonna go to the jury.
Yup.
How are you feeling about all this?
Like, what's your sense of
how this is gonna play out?
Yeah you know when your folks know my dad as an attorney.
Yeah.
But folks might not know
like I've got, you know uncles,
cousins, my older brother, all attorneys right.
I think when you get raised
in that kind of environment, around a lot of people
who study and practice law,
you know I think the one thing you learn
is to try not to be too overly prescriptive
of what a jury is gonna do.
And so, you know, I've followed the case.
I've tried not to obsess and be hypervigilant
about following the case,
because I know that at the end of the day,
you know, we don't have control
over the outcome out here.
You know, I'm interested
and you know, I've got to,
you know I think in a literal sense,
I have no proximity to the case
but obviously I have, you know people imagine
some proximity 'cause my dad's a.
I mean, what is his role specifically?
I mean, he's sort of in charge of leading the.
Yeah I think prosecution team.
Yeah and I think, you know his role I think you know
is to make sure that he's got good people in charge.
You know, Jerry Blackwell is probably gonna be
pretty well known when this is all said and done
and you know I like to think of my dad
as a pretty good trial lawyer
but I think it's probably been well over a decade
since he's been in a courtroom.
And so his role really is to build a good team
and I think and to check in with them
to you know vet their work.
You know, make sure he's seeing what they're seeing
and make sure he understands what they're seeing
and that he's equipping them with all the tools they need.
You know, aside from that.
Is he in the courtroom every day?
I, you know, I'm actually not sure
I've tried for the most part
to not get into the details of the case the same way that,
you know, I tried to make sure that he's not in the details
of like the civil side as we were dealing with that.
Because you were involved in negotiating
the settlement, right.
Right.
For the family.
Yeah.
And so you know, there's a
I think there's a healthy,
well A, I think there's just
it's just good professional behavior
for us to make sure that if there's overlap
that we're keeping it separate, right.
Yeah.
But also, you know I think people kind of imagined
me and my dad of having like this professional relationship
but like we have a personal one, right?
(all laughing)
Like, I got the same relationship with my dad
has anybody has with their dad, right.
So, you know, we get together
we're not gonna just talk about work.
You know, we got other stuff going on.
Right, I read that
'cause you're you're gonna run for re-election.
And your dad was quoted as saying something like,
"Well, I hope he's doing it because he wants."
He's like, My son's an artists men.
Like, you know, I hope he only if he wants to do it
'cause at some point
that guy's gonna go back to painting murals.
Yeah for sure.
Maybe he will, maybe he won't, I don't know.
Yeah, no that's what I love to do.
I think that I'll be, you know my impulses
will forced me back into that eventually
but right now I really feel like I'm offering
something to my community that,
I don't know anybody else could could step up
and offer and plenty of people would be capable,
you know but who can win an election
and who's ready.
Yeah.
And who feels prepared,
you know half of it is feeling yourself prepared, you know?
Yeah me and my dad, like the last couple of months
I think we've like, you know football came and went
you know, obviously we talk about a lot of like the context
same stuff everybody else talks about,
but also spend a lot of time talking about.
He's a big fan of like really bad monster movies.
Like, you know, like stuff like, oh, I'm watchable.
Like he really loves like,
like Hugh Jackman's, "Van Helsing."
I can't understand it.
(all laughing)
And he's rewatching, you know, I think the
when he can, you know not that he has a bunch of time,
but he was telling me he was gonna try
to rewatch the X-Files.
So, you know we talked about that type of stuff.
I'm trying to get them to watch "One Vision."
I don't know if it's this thing.
And it might be too new for him
going back into the X-Files mine.
Wow, what was that like growing with him as a Congressman?
I mean, most of your childhood,
he must've been in office.
Yeah so you'd have to go back and forth between DC and here.
Well, you know what's weird,
you know, I think it was 17 when he was elected.
Okay so you were already.
Yes, I was kind of up and getting out of the house
and you know, I don't know too many 16
17 year olds who really care
about what their parents are doing.
No.
So I think that he.
As a parent of a 17 year old
I can promise you zero interest.
I think it took me a long time to even realize
like that anybody thought of him
as like especially important.
You know, cause like, you know you go to DC
to the swearing in and you're there
and you know and all of that,
but at 16, 17 and I'm like,
you know, I'm thinking about football.
My you know, I was playing you know at the time
thinking about, you know whether or not
I'm gonna recover from my shoulder injury.
I'm thinking about girls, I'm thinking about art
I'm thinking about all these other things.
Yeah.
And then, you know,
and I think that like at some point
it was like I had like a realization in my early twenties.
I'm like, Oh my dad's like,
kind of like people know him.
Like a thing yeah.
(all laughing)
It's kind of weird.
So anyway but yeah it took me a while to even realize.
And so I think, you know for my younger siblings
I think it was a little bit more of a thing for them
but for me and my older brother
I think it was like dad's thing for a while.
Right and your mom's a baller too,
like director of the board of education.
Yeah.
But they were cool with like our son's an artist, man.
Like let him do his thing.
There wasn't a pressure on you
to know the law school or anything like that.
No, nothing like that, I thing.
You know in my household it was like,
you know, love what you do
try to be good at it so that we can brag about you
and that's, you know that's kind of it.
You know I remember my mom was like one of the
I can't remember how old I must have been like 12 maybe.
Yeah like 11 or 12.
And I wanted like these like Prismacolor markers
and they're like $4 a marker.
And so you need to get a set of 24,
it gets pretty expensive.
And you know, they'd always been interested in my art
but I don't think really understood like,
I think they kind of thought of it as like,
okay this is a key thing he did as a kid
he's gonna grow out of it.
And not just like remained really interested in comics
really interested in drawing, really interested in painting.
And my mom was finally like,
all right, we're gonna get this kid.
These expensive markers and let them go wild.
And it was probably a big part of like
what kept me in it.
'Cause you know, like I think I was getting a little bit
like, you know kind of run that age where it's like,
okay pen and pencil drawing still lives.
Right?
Like this is fine.
And it's like, "Oh man, I could do all kinds of things
"with color and all this other stuff."
So they always really encouraged the art making for sure.
Right.
We'll be back in a sec, but first if you dig this podcast
and I hope you dig this podcast
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book
"Voicing Change" featuring excerpts from
poignant essays by and glorious photography of some 50
of my favorite guests over the last eight plus years
of doing this thing, this podcast.
It's a gorgeous art full compendium
of the show and copious wisdom shared there in.
All wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake
or gift for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available
and we are shipping globally direct to any coffee table
on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
So the activism comes later.
I mean, we mentioned Jamar Clark in 2015,
but prior to that,
I mean you were protesting here and there, right?
Yeah.
Like you got arrested one time you,
got arrested over 15 times.
But was that was that 2015 incident?
Like the turning point was that
was that like a moment where you're like,
"Oh, I'm gonna step up and fill some shoes here.
I think it was a moment where people in my life
kind of thought,
"Hey, you're demonstrating some leadership."
I had a mentor, you know who kinda told me,
she was like I've always,
like when you were in high school
I always wanted you to sort of fill this role.
'Cause people, you know, you know they,
I've seen you give people sort of permission
in an indirect way,
give them permission to do courageous things.
And I've just kind of never thought of myself that way.
I'm out here, I'm moving through the world
trying to paint my paintings and do all that.
And even during the Jamar Clark protest,
I mean, I was spending most of my days up in my studio
and it was the activists who are on the ground
at the time who were saying like,
"Hey, you live here and we think that it would mean a lot
"to community members, to your neighbors
"if they have your presence, right."
So I would go deliver coffee
and a big part of what kept me in.
It was, you know, I was in a longer-term relationship
and my girlfriend at the time she was like in it,
she was like we're gonna like,
we're gonna be at the protest, you know?
And so I think through that relationship as well,
it was like, okay cool like there's an expectation here.
And people are telling me I'm adding some value.
In 2015 I think it was more like,
you know, yeah a lot of community members,
you know, I had actually reached out
to the council member at the time Longyang
and I went back and looked at the message
that I had sent them recently.
'Cause I just was, couldn't quite remember what I had said.
And it was just like, this really measured message
of like, "Hey, like I don't expect you to agree
"with all the protesters out here,
"but you know, I'd always had a good impression of him
"and I'd seen him running loose for County commissioner."
Then he ended up as a council member
and as my council member and I kinda thought,
you know, like I don't feel any hesitancy
reaching out to you.
And I just remember feeling so dismissed, right?
Like, couldn't it like reading the response,
I couldn't even be sure if he wrote it.
Like I was like, did his aid write this?
And just like, you know
but I remember just feeling totally dismissed.
And what I had asked him to do,
was come out and be with his neighbors.
I said, "Hey look, no matter what you,
"where you stand
"one of your neighbors was killed by a city employee."
Yeah.
And I think it's important
that you should come show your face.
And it was just no, not gonna do that.
And so that kind of, I think triggered a frustration in me
that was like,
"Well, you you gotta at least show up, right?"
Like whether people disagree with you or agree with you,
you gotta at least show up.
Whether they call you an or a thank you.
You gotta show up.
Right.
It's just important, it's just a part of the job.
The citizens of this city are not afraid
to call their elected officials ass holes.
(all laughing)
No, they're not.
As much as we have this.
I mean, you know, Minnesota Nice as is a real thing as well.
The passive aggressiveness can be overwhelming sometimes.
But definitely, especially in the last couple of years,
I mean, folks are gonna tell you what they feel
and I appreciate it even if I think somebody is wrong,
I appreciate it.
Well that rawness,
you know can lead to the change that,
you know can change everything.
I agree.
So you end up running and in like 2016
you get elected in 2017
and your platforms essentially at the time
like it has to do with police action, protest and reform
and workers' rights, housing, environmental justice
and the like, but you couldn't have imagined
what you would be in for.
No, not at all.
I, you know I actually spent,
while I was looking through
I have this spreadsheet of like things that I've authored
and things that I've liked,
you know tried projects and policy and ordinances,
that kind of thing.
And a little tracker for myself,
what's in progress, what have I finished,
what have I passed?
And all the stuff that I've passed,
you know it's all, you know, on the budget realm
it's all economic development stuff.
You know, it's helping small businesses buy their buildings
that kind of thing.
On the policy front
it's all like housing protection,
like renter protectio that kind of stuff.
I mean housing such a big deal here.
It's a huge deal.
You know, I mean, everywhere in the country,
you know you're seeing people get pushed out of urban areas
because, you know there's sort of this
I call it reverse white flight.
It's like, you know, people left in the fifties or whatever.
And now like their grandkids,
like all wanna come live in the city
and it's fine, but it's driving up home prices
and there's a lack of act like lack of access.
And it's displacing the people
who have been living in city for generations.
And so I really wanna tackle that
both the economic development issue
and the housing issue because it's like,
you know, this area is either gonna gentrify
or it's gonna stay disinvested from
how can I make sure that neither happened, right?
Like that we get investment,
but that people can stay
and keep opting into this place as their home.
So that's what I've been focused on.
And obviously there's accountability yeah.
I was just like, it's a focus,
but yeah now it's I mean,
now it's our inability to wrestle with this
for many decades.
Our inability to really wrestle with this issue
is kinda tearing our city apart right now.
Yeah.
It's tearing the whole Metro apart.
And people we'll talk about Jamal Clark
and people will talk about George Floyd and they should,
both of those people, both those men were killed
in this awful way,
but people older than me are gonna talk about,
you know, Tycel Nelson they're gonna talk about
a (indistinct) Sanders.
You know, they're gonna talk about these other people who,
you know throughout the years,
you know, have been killed by MPD
and Terrance Franklin, which was well ahead of my time.
But we didn't settle that case until I was in office.
I think he was, he was killed in 2012 or 2013.
City didn't settle that case until, until like 2020.
And so our 2019 maybe
and so yeah, I think it's a huge issue
and we've gotta get it right.
And I think that everybody has the mayor,
my colleagues, everybody has an idea
about how to get it right.
And everybody thinks the other person's wrong
including me to be fair.
And that's kind of where things stand.
Yeah the at George Floyd Square
they do a really good job
of making sure everybody understands
that although George is kind of the focal point
of that space, it's really about so much more than that.
And you see all the names painted on the street
and then there's the cemetery with tombstones
for all of the individuals who have who have fallen
at the hands of the police.
And it's just, it's impossible to not,
you know sort of be in denial
about the gravity of the problem, right.
And I wanna get to re-imagining public safety
'cause you've got lots of interesting opinions about that.
But before that, like let's spend a little bit of time
on George Floyd.
Like I'm interested in,
you know how everything story sort of begins to change
when that transpires,
you know commencing with,
like when did you first see the video
and like how did that all go down in your own life?
Yeah you know I first saw the video the day it happened.
It was at night.
I had seen snippets of it, like on social media
throughout the day, but had never been spending enough time
on social media to actually click the video.
And nobody had necessarily called me or anything.
Like usually I will have like a lot of calls
from community activists about like, this happened.
So I was kind of like.
It's not in your ward.
Yeah it's not in my ward, right exactly.
And so it was kind of like,
okay I'm not really sure what this video is
but it's late at night.
Nobody's called me about it, but I'll check it out.
And I think it was the one I saw,
what had been like re-shared or posted by Eliza Deris.
Who's an activist here, local activists here.
He wasn't the one who filmed the video
but he had this video and he had posted it.
So I'm like, okay Eliza is posting this,
it must be serious 'cause I you know,
take his opinion seriously.
And I watched the video and I just remember feeling like,
like just that dread that you feel
when as you're watching him be tortured.
And there's this moment at the end of the video
where, you know I just remember
and it's spent a while since I watched it,
but they they go to eventually pick him up
and he's so limp.
And at a human level,
you know like your instincts kick in
and your brain is telling you,
that this person doesn't have any life in them
which contrasted you know,
the call I eventually ended up getting,
which was you know, "Oh, you know
"he wasn't dead in the video.
"He passed later,"
You know all this other stuff, right.
Call from other city officials.
I got a call from the police.
Well the mayor called me first.
I did and then I saw later that I had missed a call
from the chief somehow.
And I let her talk to him about it.
And it was like, he got bad info.
Like, you know, somewhere in the chain
a lot of folks, you know bad info just started spreading.
He wanted to make sure I was, I knew what was going on.
He gave me the info he had and it just wasn't the truth.
Well, the initial police report
didn't even indicate the knee on the neck thing at all.
Right, no.
It was just.
They didn't amend that until after the video was.
Right.
And so, you know we've been struggling with some problems
with MPD even before this happened, right.
Like, you know there was my second year in office
or maybe halfway through my first year in office,
officers got, there was a report that
MPD was instructing MTS to inject people with ketamine
whether they needed it or not, right.
And you you got these transcripts of people being begging
strapped to a gurney begging to not be injected
against their will and then being injected, right.
The idea being, we just need to sedate these people.
Yeah.
By whatever means necessary.
I mean honestly reading through
some of the transcripts that I read
often it would read as this person
called me a name I didn't like.
This person, it just seemed vindictive.
You know excited delirium is often the term that's used
as an excuse to inject people with ketamine.
But you know the people who were being injected
were often totally lucid you know,
maybe mouthing off quote unquote
but totally lucid and being injected with ketamine
sort of came off as more of a punishment than anything.
Yeah.
And, you know we had this marijuana drug bust,
which you know, we shouldn't even be bothering
with that anyway,
but it was so rife with racial bias
that the district attorney wouldn't even prosecute the case.
And we did not have a progressive district attorney
you know, it was and so like,
these are some of the things that kind of led up
to, you know "Oh we have this huge report
"that you guys should look into
"the star Tribune, you know talk to a bunch of
"survivors of sexual assault
"about and talk to them about their experience."
And it was sort of this huge exposure
of like how people felt like they were treated,
not only was their case never solved.
Right and that we have this low, you know,
we clear like 20% or less of these types of cases,
but individual victims saying that they felt
totally dismissed or revictimized by our police.
Is that breakdown by race.
I don't remember if the report broke down by race,
but some of the women were,
you know, very you know very public.
And I think there's a, like a photo
with a number of some of the victims
who felt like they hadn't been
given service by the Police Department
that given any kind of sense of justice
and weren't even taken seriously.
Right and so these are the issues that we're,
you know that we're dealing with
and they're all sort of these local scandals
that like we're dealing with.
And each one just notch it.
The tension just gets ratcheted up, right.
So, you know it's easy to kind of look at Floyd
the Floyd situation and the explosion of civil unrest
that followed and conclude that it was all about that.
Without really appreciating everything
that like was leading up to that being
kind of a breaking moment for everyone.
Absolutely, you know there was one professor
from John Jay College they have,
I'm gonna blank on his name.
But he said something to the effect
of during one of our council meetings
where we were kind of having experts
come in and give us testimony.
He said something to the effect of if,
if not an insignificant number of people,
not feel like they no longer want MPD
as a part of their life.
That is a reputation that MPD has earned.
Right and so 'cause people don't come
to that conclusion overnight
they don't come to that conclusion,
out of the blue,
they witness and they experience
that nothing else will work.
Right, whether it's people who,
you know like Travis Jordan's girlfriend
who, you know he was somebody
who's having a mental health crisis.
You know, she called nine one one to get help
'cause she thought he was gonna harm himself
and the police shut up and killed him.
Whether it's, you know, people who have lost,
you know loved ones because of high-speed chases
that were like totally irresponsibly conducted.
I mean, there's a feeling from a lot of people here
that you know, they want good public safety service, right?
Yeah.
But they they're just
showing over the years.
They repeatedly been shown something otherwise.
And also, you know,
not to go too deep down the rabbit hole,
but you're also contending
with a lack of sufficient culpability for these officers.
The arbitration process doesn't really seem to do his job.
No.
So many of these officers
get reprimanded and they're back on the streets
and there's no real repercussions for that.
Right.
And so the ills are so systemic
that it leads to that deep level of mistrust
where someone like yourself is led to conclude
that it's broken beyond repair.
So the conversation around reform
falls on deaf ears for somebody like you, right.
Because it would appear to like the outsider looking in,
okay, there's problems here
but let's look at what those problems are
and like tease them out and solve them.
But your position is basically like you can't do
it's like a few bad apples.
Like Trevor Noah was talking about this on Instagram.
It's like, it's not bad apples.
It's like, the tree is rotten, right.
And if you have a rotten tree that teasing out
of what's wrong, really isn't gonna move the needle
or solve the problem in any meaningful way.
And we've teased out these problems, right.
I was reading something that a friend gave me about
you know, all these various commissions
that have studied you know,
the various major riots throughout history,
right in America.
Starting with the 1919 race riots in Chicago
known as Red Summer 1919.
Red summer happens and the governor of Illinois at the time
puts together the commission on race relations
and to study why the riots happened
and you know how they were exacerbated and fines
that in large part, they were started by the police
and that they were exacerbated by all these inequities
and talks about, you know,
literally 1919 talks about,
you know, we need to end police brutality
that will prevent further riots in the future.
We need to have police living in the communities
that they work in.
Like, they give a lot of suggestions
that you'll hear people give today.
This is 1919.
And how did they move past that?
Or have they not in your opinion?
You tell me how many
how many scandals the Chicago Police Department
has had since 1919.
I mean, I couldn't tell you, I don't know.
I mean, I will say it's plenty.
I would argue that they haven't moved past it.
And I would argue that we haven't moved past it.
I think that ultimately, this isn't the problem,
you know locally, we do have a problem
with this department but if you Zoom out,
the problem that we're having with this department
is not a problem with only this department.
This is a problem that every single city is facing
with their departments.
It's a matter of a lack of accountability.
You can have all the training in the world
but if you're not gonna be held accountable
your training never matters.
Right, you can have all the good intentions in the world
but if you know that there's never any accountability
then when you fail to meet your good intention
it doesn't really matter.
And I think that's the system that we've created.
And we pour tons of money into reforms.
I mean I think that's the one thing
people don't understand is that,
a lot of these reforms costs additional money, right?
Whether it's facial recognition,
whether it's, you know body cameras,
they cost a ton of more trainings,
they cost a ton of money.
And yet the settlement amounts yeah.
Here in Minneapolis, but also you know,
there there was a $20 million settlement
in Maryland just earlier this year,
or maybe in 2020 the settlements just get bigger.
So the cost of the apartment gets bigger.
The behavior doesn't change,
the issue doesn't change the settlements get bigger.
I mean, at what point do cities just,
are we just not able to even afford
this model of public safety?
Yeah.
I think we're pretty much there.
Yeah the heartbreak of, of George Floyd
as sort of emotionally challenging as all of this is
has for better or worse
kind of foisted you into the national spotlight.
You go from being, you know ward five city councilmen
to suddenly being on national news.
And the main thing that you're speaking to
is this idea of finding new ways to keep ourselves
and our neighbors safe, right.
But this is all couched in the vernacular
around Defund the Police.
And my sense, and this is
I really wanna hear what you have to say, about this is.
I think the defund the police means many different things
to many different people, depending on who you talk about.
My sense is that it's less about like eradicating
or abolishing a police force and much more
about ending the monopolization of public protection
in the hands of this broken system
and creating a new public safety kind of
you know program at large of which police
are but one part of.
Is that fair.
'Cause you're sort of like, "Oh Jeremiah
"he's the defund the police guy."
Yeah right.
You know what I mean so like what does that mean to you?
And like, where do you stand and how has that
also, like how has your perspective
or your position on this evolved over the last year?
Yeah I'll say this as I'm, you know
'cause right now it is reelection time.
Right as I'm on the phones
and I'm talking to people
maybe even more than usual constituents, more than usual.
And I'm finding that for the most part
and I know this probably surprises some people
but for the most part
I'm finding that I still have plenty of support.
And that even my neighbors who are not 100%
where I'm at, they are open to the City of Minneapolis,
spending less money on police.
What they're not open to
is us spending less money on their overall safety, right?
To me, that means
that any system that we want
that's different than than what we have
we've gotta create it.
That's the only way that we can bring people along.
Right we've gotta create it.
And so I think for me,
the term defund right, defund the police
it's a term created by activists, not me right.
Term created by activists to generate a conversation.
It's definitely done that.
It's done that.
It's as provocative as it comes
It's generated a conversation
but it doesn't have anything to do with governing, right?
So activists are well within their right to make that call.
It's my job, to listen to community members and ask myself
in what way can I make this relevant to governing?
And the way that it can be relevant in governing
is that we've got to assess
all the ways in which people expect to be kept safe, right?
If we are expected by our community and we should be
to solve rape cases then we've gotta also admit
that we're currently not doing that.
Our current system is not doing that.
If people expect that if they have a loved one
in the throws of a mental health crisis
that their city is not gonna show up
and fucking kill that person
then we've gotta create a system that functions that way.
Right and if people X
and if people who had H who have had a fender bender
still wanna get a report for insurance
but don't necessarily wanna have to interact
with a police officer
then we should create a system where that's possible.
Yeah, it is interesting because now
no matter what situation you find yourself in
the cops are the only like 911 and it's the cops.
So whether it's a paramedic situation
or a mental health problem, or a simple,
you know skirmish that could be,
you know managed effectively through some kind of,
you know community.
Mediation or something like that.
Outreach or something like that.
Yeah there seems to be a lot of situations
and circumstances in which
the police need not be involved,
particularly in a situation
where there's such a level of distrust.
Yeah I mean, I know that the fake $20 bill quote unquote,
it's an alleged fake $20 of dollar bill.
I don't know if it's ever been confirmed
that George Floyd used.
Where is that bill.
I have no idea.
It didn't turn up in evidence did it?
That's a great question.
No one now talks about that.
But this alleged fake $20 bill, even if it was real
did it require four guys with guns to respond?
I mean, that's not an armed robbery.
That's not even a heist, right?
Like that's not any kind of an emergency
that four armed people need to come and address.
I think that we've gotta have a response.
We've gotta have a system
that can still address that store's need.
Right, "Hey, we're out 20 bucks.
"If this happens too often,
"like where it's not great for us."
But we also need a system that,
I mean, our only way,
I mean, did that store ever get its 20 bucks back, right?
Like, we didn't do any sort of remedy for that store
in that moment.
All the city did, all the police did was killed George Floyd
as a response to this alleged fake $20 bill.
What public safety need was met
I think is the question that we've gotta ask ourselves.
And if the answer is none
and you know I assert that the answer is none.
Then what do we need, right.
Because the store needed you know,
a response for the emergency that they were having
or for the incident that they were having.
But George Floyd safety also mattered in that moment.
And in our system, we prioritized
we didn't prioritize anyone's safety
but we definitely prioritized sort of a punitive response
to someone we thought might've been creating some harm.
Yeah how does that relate to our kind of parochial notion
of what it means to protect and serve, right.
Yeah.
I mean, certainly,
you know in some communities likely not all,
there was a date and a time
where the police officers were embedded in the community
and they were community members
and they were looked to for guidance and counsel
and they knew, you know
those officers knew the people in the community.
That's a far cry from what we have today,
which is a pivot in the opposite direction
towards these militarized you know, essentially SWAT teams
that you see increasingly you know, across the country.
But even that first, but even that,
that older model where you did have folks
who lived in the area,
that model never work for black community.
Yeah, that's what I said, kind of parochial
and whether or not that was actually true.
Right now, fair enough.
And you know, you've got images
of not only police starting race riots in 1919
but you know, you've got it happening in the '20s
and then in the 30s and you know,
you got it happening in Harlem
and you've gotta happening and in LA, right.
And so I think that there's this,
the Chicago, the trial of the Chicago Seven
is about, you know the police starting a riot, you know?
And so I think that we've got to vet the whole thing.
Right, like I think that, you know
NPDs been around for 153 years,
you know I think that
we shouldn't finger wag at how it functions now
and say well we've just got to address that.
Right.
I think we should maybe take inventory
of how the last 153 years have gone, you know in total.
And if we haven't gotten
what we needed out of the system,
then yeah I think that.
And again, I think we haven't
then I don't think it's reactionary.
I don't think 102 years is reactionary
to say I think it's time for a different conversation.
Right, but you're often characterized as reactionary.
Yeah, I think this movement is yeah
For sure.
I mean, there was the moment
sometime after the protests were reaching their peak
where you among nine city council members
wanted to amend the city charter
so that you could put into motion
this kind of department of
Department public safety.
Right, exactly.
Which would kind of upend the traditional way
that the police operated
that didn't pass or didn't get onto the ballot, right.
But it's gonna be on the ballot in November, I think.
Right so we didn't proceed forward quickly enough
to get it on the ballot for 2020.
But now not only is there a council amendment
there there's a community amendment
also proceeding forward the language is pretty similar.
There's some, I think there's some key differences
but I think that even if the council
had given up on that effort
the community was like, "No, we want this"
and they're gonna they're gonna
make sure it's on the ballot.
Right.
And so I think that, that,
I think that only affirms
that this impulse, wasn't some kind of
Minneapolis City Council impulse
that you now have in order to get
for a citizens petition to end up on the ballot
in Minneapolis, they have to get,
I think a little over 20,000 signatures.
Right.
So now you've got
20,000 votes that are for sure
gonna be cast for this thing, if not more, right.
That's, you're nearing a mandate
from your neighbors, from your residents.
When they're saying,
even if you don't bring forward this charter change,
we will.
Right, meanwhile, you have made some progress, right?
There's this something like $8 million
have been redirected to other public safety measures.
Yup.
There's a restricted use on choke holds.
And you know, there's been a raising of the threshold
for the use of force.
There's these violence interrupters
these guys are cruising around and orange t-shirts
and kind of mediate conflict.
Yup.
In various neighborhoods,
this office of violence prevention.
Yep.
Right.
(indistinct) health department.
So there has been some kind of movement in the direction
that you'd like to see.
I'm sure very far from what you would prefer to see
at the same time you know,
the counterpoint would be that
that this whole movement has led to
an increase in violent crime.
And meanwhile, like 200 police officers have quit
and violence is on the rise.
So like, how do you
I just wanna give you an opportunity.
Yeah.
To like share your thoughts on that or respond to that.
Yeah it's funny I was having a conversation
with a friend of mine.
He reminded me of this recently.
This is before George Floyd even happened.
It was before the killing of George Floyd even happened.
And when everything started shutting down
and all these people started going out of work
he was reminding me that I told him then,
I said, "You know look,
"whenever people are out of work,
"crime goes up."
And I said, "Crime is gonna go up
"and people are gonna ask for more police."
Right.
That was my prediction
then, that's how it works, right.
I think that, you know, it would be,
I think, a little out of place for me to say
that the unrest from the summer played no role
in the increase in violent crime that we had this summer.
I don't know but neither did the police,
neither does the mayor.
Neither do the people who are making this claim.
And what makes more sense and has more,
and is backed by more evidence throughout history
is that when people are out of work, crime goes up.
We had to, we had both of these things happen
at the same time, right?
You've got communities
who are some communities in Minneapolis
who are already poor facing becoming more poor.
And then those same communities
feeling incredibly disillusioned and disaffected
by the killing of George Floyd.
You know, that is gonna cause a reaction
Yeah powerful combination.
Right and so yeah,
we've had this this uptake in violence,
we've had this spike in violence this past year.
But when, if you talk to a lot of North Side youth,
right I represent North Minneapolis.
It's not, the only place
that's has an increase in violence,
but when you talk to,
but a lot of youth have been involved
in the violence that has occurred over the last year.
And if you go talk to youth directly
about what will keep them safe most of them,
I mean, I don't think I've talked to a single teenager,
you know a single person on
a single teenager in North Minneapolis
who has said the issue is that we don't have enough police.
They'll say the issue is that we don't have anything to do.
The issue is that people are hungry in their house.
And they can't go to school now.
They can't go to school, right?
Yeah people are hungry in their houses.
And they can't get that meal
that they would get at school.
They can't get that meal that we get in school
also you know, they're at that age
where they wanna take risks, they want to be bold.
They want to, you know and when you combine that
with access to a firearm,
with access to you know,
with all the things that a teenager wants
the desire to feel powerful.
Yeah you're gonna have,
you're gonna have some.
And an environment right
now where it's kind of like at anything goes.
Yeah.
You know, right.
Then you're gonna have these increases in violence.
I will say that the other thing I would say,
is that people would have to also be claiming
that there was a rise of violence because of a declaration.
Right, because the city council made a deli declaration.
Right.
And that, that caused a spike of violence,
And that kid who's perpetrating the crime has no idea.
Yes, and it's not.
playing into the.
That kid is not on my newsletter.
Yeah.
I, you know I'll say that,
he has no idea what they city councils is up to
because we didn't, we didn't address,
we didn't remove 5% of the police's budget
until December of 2020, right.
And so when you see this this spike in violence
over the summer, what's your witnessing
is the old model at work.
What's your witnessing is the status quo at work
fully funded, you know,
I think the year 2020,
Minneapolis police department had more money
than they'd ever had
in the history of their department.
And so, we didn't actually even reallocate 10%
of their 5% sorry, we didn't even reallocate 5%
of their budget until December of 2020.
And so, you know,
so the argument to me
starts to really falter when you actually examine it
fed it in any in any way.
And what makes more sense
is again this economic issue,
conflated with the pandemic,
people out of school and all that stuff.
Have you looked at,
do you know this thing Campaign Zero from DeRay Mckesson?
You know, who DeRay Mckesson is?
Yeah I know who DeRay is I don't know, I will admit,
I don't know a ton about that you know.
So he's got this.
I mean, you know police reform is one of his big things
but he started this kind of initiative
non-profit initiative called Campaign Zero.
And it's all about police reform
and the took all of these people
who've actually studied this
and figured out what's effective and what's not.
'Cause a lot of the things you think would be good
actually don't end up translating
into any kind of fungible change.
And they looked at like
what are the things that move the needle?
And he's got this website
and it's like here are the 10 things
that are actually effective in reforming police.
But that's not really the game you're playing.
Like you're playing your role in a different paradise,
Right.
For this whole thing.
Right I think that like, I'd be happy to check it out
and just make sure that I,
it's probably a lot of the stuff
that other people are recommending.
I'll say that, because a lot of these reforms,
they all come out of the same school of thought
and they all make the same base assumption.
And that base assumption is that policing
is the only way to conduct public safety.
And so I'm not accusing DeRay that I don't know.
I'll have to check out his 10 points
but I will say that like, you know
you go through and you look at what people are saying today.
And you look at things that came out of,
you know the Macon Commission or the Kerner Commission
you know, or any of these things
that any of these studies that came out of these riots
and they they've been making the same recommendations
in the Illinois Commission On Race Relations.
They've been making the same recommendations for 100 years.
And so my question is,
what other than policing would work,
you know, to achieve our goals?
Well, that was the one thing you talked about,
this idea of the police having a monopoly on public safety.
And I gotta admit,
like I never really thought about that before.
I was like, they do have a monopoly on that and why is that?
Is it supposed to be that way?
Should it be that way?
I never asked myself that question before.
Right.
But the idea
that it doesn't need to be that way
and perhaps there is a different way.
Right.
The only thing that I can
think of that resembles that in any regard,
I mean I lived in New York City in the late '80s
and I remember the guardian angels everywhere,
like on the subway.
And it was kind of like this community-based,
you know mediation squad who was there to kind of diffuse
any kind of conflicts that would occur.
You wanna talk about defunding,
those kinds of efforts have popped up over cities, right?
Like whenever cities at peak crisis,
they employ these kinds of efforts, right.
They hire people that maybe used to
be in a life of violence,
but, you.
Right.
Reform themselves.
It's usually those guys
And it has an impact, right.
It might take a year or two or three, but it has an impact.
And then as soon as they're, as soon as crisis averted.
They go away.
They go away
Yeah, yeah.
And it's because,
you know, it would,
we always sort of view those kinds of things
as sort of tag on's right.
They're like band-aids.
Mediate right exactly.
But to me, what's more common.
Right, I guess I'll pose it as a question.
What's more common,
a dispute between a domestic dispute,
between a couple, right?
Or a dispute between neighbors
or an active shooter situation.
What's more common, right?
Well probably depends on the neighborhood
but you know, probably you know,
the domestic dispute situation.
Right.
And what's more common that somebody is
maybe having some kind of mental health emergency, right.
Whether it's you know, severe depression,
they're gonna take their own life.
Whether it's paranoid schizophrenia
they didn't take their medication.
Whether, you know, any number of
or they have a trauma and they get triggered, right.
Or are a bunch of, you know
heavily armed guys on the freeway
gonna March down and just start indiscriminate.
Yeah.
Murdering everybody on the site.
I mean.
Now I get it.
Yeah I get it.
And so to me, like to have somebody
to have like someone in a mediator role
to have someone in like a who's a mental health specialist,
it just makes more sense
for that to be more of a staple.
I'm not saying that you know,
there's no role for guys with guns in the.
In our country there just should be
more tools in the toolbox basically.
Yeah there should be right, not everything needs to be.
So what does it look like? Like if you had your druthers
the ideal scenario that could play out in this city,
forget about politics.
Sure
Like here's the,
here's what I would like to enact
that I think would solve these problems.
Yeah well you know, I think that
my pragmatic brain sort of kicks in
and I'm like, well nothing will be like ready tomorrow
at scale but that, even that aside, right.
The office of violence prevention
we established it in 2018 with 1/2 a million dollars.
Now the office has.
7 million,
I think is a budget.
I think it's 2.5.
I think what I read,
I could have it wrong,
but 2.5 got directed towards it.
So that amped up the budget to seven.
Oh, okay I yeah I'll vet that.
Yeah you might be right on that.
So it's exponential growth,
but whether it's 2.5 or 7 million,
that pales in comparison to.
What it was.
170, right 170 million is what we give the police, right.
You know what we've set aside
to build our mental health program
is a couple million dollars, it's gonna go very far.
It's gonna help get that, jump start that program
and hopefully integrate it into our 911 system.
So it doesn't have to have its own long seven digit number
and all of that, but whatever their budget is
it's gonna pale in comparison to that 1.7 million.
To me I think that we need to constant,
we need to be in a constant state of evaluation
of what do we need an armed force for, right.
When when is use of force actually appropriate?
When.
And who gets to make that decision?
And who gets to make that decision.
When.
Also shit happens too, right?
That would be the counterpoint.
When has, but you can back that up with data, right?
Like you can have,
I think it was like the "New York Times"
that put up this thing,
that like police spend about 4% of their time
actually in and engaging in a violent situation.
Right 4% of their time.
I'm not saying that you need to reduce your
what your police do all the way down to 4% of public safety.
But what I'm saying is that,
I do think that it's worthwhile to examine reality.
Right, you can run hypotheticals until your brain is tired.
Right you can, what if this happen, what if that happens?
What if blah, blah
and what I would say is that like,
when have the police ever met that public need, right?
When have the police ever met the,
met the public safety standard
that they say they're meeting, right.
When have they been successful right?
I can point to a lot of situations
in which not only did the police mess up
but they weren't even successful,
they weren't even successful
in meeting any public safety standard at all, right.
And so I think that, how do we avoid that?
Right, how do we avoid not meeting
any public safety standard at all?
I think it's worthwhile to ask ourselves.
And I think it's totally fair to say
you know, "How did X scenario go?"
How does X scenario usually go,
you know whether it's a mental health crisis response
or domestic response
and ask yourself, are the police having an effect here,
a positive one, are they meeting
any sort of public safety goal that we have as a city?
And if the answer is yes
but they could use some improvement here and there,
then great.
If the answer is no,
then we should probably develop a different strategy.
You know, I think that
what we're experiencing is that
you have a whole bunch of people that say,
"It's not even fair to ask the question.
"It's not okay to even ask the question."
Right the question's dangerous.
It's fascinating
because everything you're saying makes really good sense.
And it's crazy that it's such a delicate subject
and so difficult to just sit down
and rationally walk through it.
Because I think it part
that is perhaps informed by just, you know,
sort of rash impulsive reactions to the idea
of messing with the police force at all.
And I don't think it's helped by,
like, we all saw the video of Mayor Frey,
you know, being asked like are you gonna,
you know are you gonna defund the police?
And he said, "Well, if you mean abolish a police force,
"like I don't support that."
And it was in the middle of a huge protest
and they said shame and he had to kind of walk
through this crowd.
It's like, okay like you and him have different opinions
on all of this, but what you're saying
isn't like a yes or no question
are we abolishing the police department?
Like, this is a well thought out nuanced perspective
on improving public safety
that is comprehensive and involves the police
in appropriate circumstances.
Yeah.
How dare you?
You know what I mean?
I mean.
'Cause you are like,
it's like, oh Jeremiah, he's the defund guy.
Yeah.
You stay away from that guy.
Yeah, that's narrative,
like that's that's narrative for you though.
Right, like there are people who feel
like they would benefit politically
if they could prevent people
from hearing me ask the question.
And you have, you don't have that many opportunities
to kind of talk on and on like we're doing here
it's in soundbites.
It's in super quick, yeah.
And if you don't nail it,
like they're gonna, you know sort of position you,
however they feel like
or whatever is gonna get the most clicks.
Yeah oh for sure, for sure.
And I've accepted that,
you know, you about,
like I started off this whole thing
as the council member for the fifth ward
and now I'm you know, getting public interviews
I would say I'm still the council member for the fifth ward.
And the only thing that matters to me, right.
I'm interested in these conversations
because quite frankly, I think you know
it just kind of sharpens my ability to talk about it
and I'm gonna, you know take some lessons
from this conversation
and I'm gonna apply it to my conversations
on the phones, with people with my neighbors
who I'm talking about this stuff with every single day.
Right, but for me the work is not conversations
like this one.
It's great to have it, it's great to,
you've got a tremendous platform
and I appreciate the way you're using it.
Right but for me, the council member of ward five
here in Minneapolis, and I don't have to convince
I don't have to convince anybody on the news.
I don't have to convince people in St. Paul.
I don't have to convince people on the coast.
I don't have to convince Congress,
I don't have to convince, you know
I've enjoyed this conversation, I really liked you.
I don't have to convince you even, right.
Yeah you don't have to do anything,
you have to show up here, but I wouldn't say,
that yeah you have to convince your constituents.
And I gotta convince my colleagues.
If your constituents to flip on the news.
Sure.
And they're like, "Well he seemed like a nice guy
"when he came through yesterday
"but now he looks like a crazy person."
Sure.
You know here
like I'm not so sure.
Yeah.
Luckily I haven't gotten that feedback.
I know it exists out there
and I know that there's those narratives,
but I mean I guess I'm lucky enough to yeah.
What is the, what is like the question that you
wish you got asked in those interviews?
Or what is the confusion, if there isn't any
that you would like to clear up or that frustrates you
when you see those news pieces.
You know when we just got done now,
talking about kind of the nuances of how you execute, right.
A call to, how a call a broad call to action
gets sort of channeled and interpreted into governing.
That's the kind of conversation I wanna be having, right?
Because it's the kind of conversation
that I'm gonna have to have one way or another.
If I wanna get anything done.
Right.
These are not binary, you know situations.
They're not and I can appreciate that like,
you know some conversations are gonna be three minutes,
right and that I've gotta be able to have
a three minute response that is at least approximate
to the 90 minute conversation I can have.
Right, but I also think it's important
that these conversations not get reduced
to the three minute response.
It's much easier to say,
you said a thing in public and then crime went up.
It's stupid, but it's much easier to say
than to have this conversation
about what actually drives up crime.
Like what the impact of the pandemic
and the economic crisis have had on safety.
It's easier to say that
but then you have to ask yourself,
well crime also went up in New York and Chicago,
you know cities and Arizona.
And, you know and then you have to say,
"Is that the Minneapolis city council's fault too?
You know like then, then it's like,
you know now you're giving me,
you know sort of the kind of power
that nobody actually has, right.
And so you know that doesn't really make any sense,
but it's easier to say
and you can say it in a short amount of time.
It's harder for me to say,
how do you go about this?
How do you turn this into governing?
I actually can't quite answer
that question in three minutes.
Right, I can answer what we've done in three minutes
but even then I can't really get into the details, right.
You know, 5% of their budget, a million dollars
to these things.
It's important and I should say it,
but yeah I think that if there were more opportunities
for folks to engage in a more long form conversation
that's how we're actually gonna cook up a solution to me.
And if people, you know could,
you know I guess I'll challenge myself
to help people not have such short memories
about what has happened in the past,
because I think that plays a role in it too.
The only way that you could be accused
of being reactionary for questioning,
102 year old conversation
that has not moved one inch in those 102 years
is if people have consistently had really short memories
about these kinds of incidences the impacts that they've had
the tragedies that they've caused.
And so, you know I've gotta be patient with people
and help them not have such short memories.
Right, so at the same time,
you must have some kind of game plan
in the event that Chauvin gets released
and is not convicted, right.
'Cause the city is gonna spark,
like do you have a sense of how you would respond to that?
You must have thought about that of course
You know, in the during the summer,
you know when there was just you know,
the unrest kind of just dragged on and on and on,
there were groups of neighbors who sort of,
some armed, some unarmed
who decided to sort of engage
in their own sort of patrols.
Right sort of like an amped up,
you know neighborhood watch type thing.
And myself and council member Phillipe Cunningham
noticed that not all of the groups knew each other
and that we didn't want groups who were armed
and maybe driving around or you know,
so like coming to conflict with people
who literally live a couple blocks from them.
And so we tried to play sort of that connective tissue.
I was out doing patrols myself
and people knew that they could text or call me.
And if they couldn't get through to 911,
then I had a direct line to the, you know,
the commander of the precinct
and that I could sort of help them address their problem.
And that if I couldn't get that,
I would drive to their location and help them myself, right.
You know, as one individual,
you know I'm not incredibly superhuman,
you know, you met me I'm not incredibly tall
or you know, all that stuff, but.
You're kinda jacked.
I try, yeah.
I'm not gonna be Batman.
Right I just don't have the capacity,
but I don't think anyone does,
but I'll probably be out there
with my neighbors and trying to make sure
that people are safe, trying to make sure that,
you know their property is not,
you know, lit on fire and all of that.
I think there's also just this huge,
you know, if you're not in Minneapolis, you know,
I don't blame you for not,
like discerning the local geography.
Right, but like for folks who maybe don't
know all the protests were happening miles
from where I represent.
Right
Right, you're way north.
Yeah I was I was surprised how far South
George Floyd Square is.
Yeah and so that, you know,
so for and there were no protests,
no marches, no nothing happening in North Minneapolis.
But what we had was, we had these spontaneous fires
that got started, not by crowds, not by protestors,
not by activists, not by any of that and.
You're talking about like auto zone and the precinct.
That was South side, North side,
we had, you know gas stations,
businesses, that kind of stuff being lit on fire.
And so it was kind of odd, right.
People like, okay, we're not having protests over here.
Why are things getting lit on fire?
And so there was, you know there were a few times
there was one time in particular where,
you know we got a call from a neighbor.
Me and my friend Mike and my younger brother,
we arrived at the scene of this fire
before the firetrucks, even.
And we're it was a business called the Fade factory.
It's a barbershop
and we were just like trying to help
the small business owner,
like put the fire out in his shop.
And we were unsuccessful I just remember like pouring water,
like running water hoses from people's houses.
And like, the heat was kind of incredible.
And then all of a sudden, like the two,
like windows just on either side of us just shattered.
And it was like, we're not gonna defeat this fire
with these home home hoses, right.
That was what I did the first time
and I'll continue to be out there
and do stuff like that the second time.
You know, I'm not as convinced,
that the city, well maybe now that we've had
Dante Wright killed in Brooklyn center,
which is a nearby suburb.
I mean, it's essentially here in North Minneapolis,
but it's like North, North Minneapolis
and it's not technically Minneapolis
has its own mayor it's own police force.
Right, but I'll tell you right now
that like I have constituents who,
you know, who move around quite a bit right.
And, you know they'll live in Minneapolis
they'll live in North Minneapolis.
They might go live in the golden Valley
which is a nearby suburb,
but they're definitely gonna go live in Brooklyn Park
or Brooklyn Center,
which is in Brooklyn Centers where that happened.
I mean, it's, you know,
there are the borders that governments create
and then there are the borders that people create.
And, you know from North Minneapolis to Brooklyn Center
there's essentially no border.
Right, like people don't even treat it like it's different.
Right and so you know,
I still kind of consider that happening
kind of basically in my neighborhood.
Yeah.
I'm not as convinced that,
you know there's just gonna be chaos.
I will say that in my experience, being on the ground,
the way police response respond to protesters.
And I don't think it has to be this way
but the way they respond contributes to chaos.
And when you have that kind of chaos
you're gonna have all kinds of activity
start to happen, right.
When the police consistently are claiming
that they cannot distinguish between peaceful protestors
and somebody who threw a water bottle
and they dump gas and mason,
rubber bullets and flash bangs on the entire crowd,
you know they're gonna be people who look at that and say.
"Game on."
Yeah, there's an opportunity here.
They're gonna be people who are off
who think they're in a fight for their life
and the police response is proving them right, right.
But that's how they're gonna feel.
Yeah, they just, it feeds off each other.
Right.
And escalates.
The difference now being of course,
that the national guard is here, right.
So that's different, what's interesting about that is
at peak George Floyd protests, there was the whole kerfuffle
with the mayor with Donald Trump, right.
He was calling him weak.
And, you know, saying that
if Frey didn't call in the National Guard
he was gonna do it because,
you know when the looting starts, the shooting starts right.
That famous tweet.
And Mayor Frey didn't call him the National Guard
but now he did.
And so here we are in a situation
on the eve of a verdict being delivered
in the midst of Don the Dante Wrights situation.
So there is a pins and needles kind of vibe
everywhere you go.
And on top of that, this curfew,
and you got a lot of opinions about
how curfews work to derail or curtail freedom of association
and freedom of speech.
What is your take on, you know seeing these Humvees
all over town right now?
Yeah I think that
it probably invites the very kind of activity
and actors that it's meant to deter, to be honest with you.
I mean the fences certainly do that
you might as well put the big.
The barbed wire and the fences
and the barricades everywhere.
Yeah, absolutely.
It is like a war zone, it's crazy.
Yeah I mean, you know.
There was somebody,
my guys were walking around downtown
and they bumped up against the German woman
who was saying that.
Some elderly German woman who said,
something along the lines of like,
I haven't seen anything like this since, you know Berlin.
Yeah I mean, it was funny right before
I was just about to say, I described to my sister.
I was like, "Yeah, they literally have
"two fences with barbed wire in the middle."
And her response was, that's how the Berlin wall was built.
And I'm like that's not a great sign.
Right.
I, you know.
And it's been wild to watch the,
like I click on CNN and first of all
it's crazy to like be here and then turn CNN on.
And it's like, everything all day long
is about what's happening here.
Yeah right.
It's like this, even when we were at George Floyd square,
one of the guys we were with went into Cup Foods
and it's of course it's on and there too.
Yeah.
And it's like, it's so meta right.
And like strange, like some crazy simulation.
Yeah.
But in the context of the Dante Wright protests,
you turn on CNN and you can just hear,
like, it's all about like,
what's gonna happen when the clock ticks 10
and it's curfew and everybody's like getting ready
for some major clash, hasn't happened yet.
Yeah.
I know there's been
some that's gone down but in the grander scheme of things.
It's mostly just.
Pretty chill.
It's mostly just the military.
And like Tuesday night
there were like 10 people there,
okay after curfew everybody left.
Yeah it's mostly just the police in the military
dumping gas on people.
Like, you know and I think that that's like
I mean, you know they, in some ways
they have to do that, right.
They predicted this violent crazed fallout,
people in Minneapolis and surrounding area
were gonna react in this way.
They prepared for months for the scenario
that they wanted which is, you know,
their opportunity to have the resources to suppress a crowd.
And so when it didn't happen
they kinda had to pretend like it was happening anyway.
That's the sense that I get yeah.
And I think it's kind of sad.
And for anybody who's been,
who was out in Brooklyn Center,
you know I've always had a really good impression
of the governor but I saw the other day,
he or maybe earlier today, time is a flat circle these days.
He said that he believed
that if the barricades hadn't gone up
and the military hadn't gone out there
that the Police Precinct in Brooklyn Center
was gonna go up in flames.
I can't think of a thing,
I've never heard an elected official,
no matter their party say something
so more full of shit than that.
'Cause if you're there and I was there
and you're reading the room
and you're getting the mood of the crowd,
you know you kind of get a sense of where things are at.
You literally had activists leaders out there
who were you know, gently urging people to go home.
Most of them did I mean,
the type of people who themselves
you would think would not go home,
were urging people to go home.
I mean, the tone is just,
people are mourning, whatever fantasy the governor has
about these rabid people who can't control their impulses
who wanna burn everything down
it doesn't exist except in his fantasy.
It's usually a reaction to some level of provocation.
It's almost always that,
I mean it's pretty much, I've only ever seen it be that.
There's always gonna be bad actors though.
For sure.
Okay, this is lawless like nobody's gonna know,
you know there's not gonna be any cops showing up
so we're just gonna go do what we're gonna do.
Yeah, I mean for sure, right.
You're gonna have people who think, "Okay cool.
"This is an opportunity to go break into the store
"and steal some stuff that I could,
"you know sell later or own or whatever."
Right, you're always gonna have that.
But to pretend like the entire crowd is that,
or to just say, "Oh, there's no way for us to distinguish."
It's not true.
And you know I know I generally try to keep a calm demeanor
but it infuriates me to kind of the know
to no end when I see that.
And the rhetorical violence, right.
You're not saying, you know, you don't see it.
The governor's not seeing what he's articulating.
So he has to sort of implant that image in your mind
with his words.
All right, it's all he has
'cause he can't show you that 'cause it doesn't exist.
He has to implant that in your mind with his words.
And a lot of a lot of elected officials govern that way.
And it's just to provide some rhetorical cover
when they go ahead and abuse, you know our neighbors.
I think the part of the challenge
or the uphill battle that you're trying to wage
is convincing a guy like that
that there's value in doing something different.
Like we've seen the evidence that like
every time you do it this way, this is what happens.
Yeah.
But if you're that guy you're like, well.
Maybe we just need more force.
Yeah it's like, it's too risky.
You know what I mean?
If he's trying to please you know his constituents
or whoever he is answering to in that regard.
Sure.
It's like I know if I do this,
it might not go so good, but this is what we do.
And so I can take comfort.
If I to do something different, yeah.
I can take comfort in that.
Whereas if I go out on a limb and say,
we're not gonna do any of that,
we're gonna allow these protesters to like, do their thing.
And I promise you it's gonna be chill
and something goes sideways.
Then it's like you were.
And that dude's head is on a stick.
Sure I mean, one is,
I'm not advocating that when tensions are high,
that you do nothing, right.
I do think that when you have folks like myself
or folks like, you know Steve Fletcher, Lisa Bender
you know these are my colleagues on the council.
When you have like a handful of folks advocating,
you know that we do it differently.
Right and we've never done it differently before
but we think that if we all engaged
our collective imagination and we all engage our comments
our collective common sense
that we could probably do something pretty good.
But when you got three, five, seven, nine people
and then you have the governor,
you know the commissioner of public safety,
the police chief of the city of various cities
and the Hennepin County Sheriff,
all saying, "We're gonna do it this way."
And you're like,
"Okay, I think we should do it differently."
And they're like, "Well, how."
You have, we collectively
thought of this really abusive response.
And it took all of us, all of our brains together
working together to think of this really abusive response.
But the non abusive response,
the one that does that isn't rooted in violence.
You've got to come up with that on your own,
if we don't like it, we're just gonna tell you you're crazy.
Right I mean, that's the criticism
that gets hurled at you.
Like, "Oh, you want this different way.
"Well, show us what that is.
"And, you know, you haven't come up with that."
Right.
In specifics.
And the truth is that in a lot of ways I have right.
When it comes to thinking out this department
of public safety and the ways that we should examine safety
and proceed forward,
that I've have thought out.
When it comes to how you deescalate a crowd
that is full of raw emotion, I've got some ideas.
I do think that it would be worthwhile
for me to vet those ideas with other smart people
and, you know have my ideas challenged
and shaped into a plan, right.
Like, I think.
And shouldn't that involve
like an organizational psychologist
or like somebody who understands,
like, you know the appropriate response
to diffuse tense emotions.
Right, it should at least involved the governor.
Right, it should at least involve the mayor.
Right and it doesn't involve even those part.
Like, you know I think the standard is crazy, right?
Like they come to get,
they understand the value of collective imagination.
They all worked together to collectively imagine
this plan that they're executing, that's going really badly.
Right.
But tradition has momentum.
But traditional has momentum.
And the expectation is that if you wanna do it differently
that you've gotta come up with that on your own.
We did it together, we use the power of collaboration.
Oh, but what you wanna collaborate?
That, no that just means
that you don't know what you're doing.
And so the standards for,
the standards are just different
and they're, you know to a ridiculous degree.
Yeah, so who is getting it right?
Like is there a model out there of a city
that's executing in a way that you think Minneapolis
could aspire to emulate?
I'll be honest with you,
I don't know that any city government is getting it right.
What about internationally?
Like any, any places in Europe or you know,
I mean their relationship to policing
is completely different.
Yeah it is completely different.
Their gun laws are different, you know they,
you know I think that they've built a system
that they can sustain, right.
And, you know I think there's a whole host of reasons why
maybe it would be difficult to copy that, right.
I do think that, like when you look
at what other cities have done around,
you know doing a better job
of ensuring housing and addressing homelessness.
Right and but it's not just homelessness.
'Cause the homeless quite frankly
are not the ones out here committing most crimes, right.
It's people who might be housed
but are financially insecure and you know,
And completely disenfranchised.
And disenfranchised, and you know,
your options for them are that they can starve to death
or they can go out and try to create
a little bit of opportunity for themselves.
And they're opting to live, right.
Maybe in a way that harms others
and that's not okay, but you also haven't,
we also haven't set some people up for success.
I think that, you know there are some folks
who are starting, I think you know I keep using this phrase,
ask the question, it's not like a slogan or anything.
I just, it was just kind of how the conversation evolved.
But like, I think there are some folks
who are asking the right questions.
Right you know, Mayor Myrick in Ithaca, New York
is like asking the right questions.
He's actually taking this department
of public safety concept.
I don't know, I don't necessarily know
that he got it from us,
but he's certainly moving much faster than us
in trying to execute something like that, right.
And I certainly think that like, folks,
like you know, it's too bad that like Michael Tubbs,
you know ended up losing his election
because, you know instituting things like,
you know, universal basic income
and experimenting and figuring out
how we can do those kinds of policies.
I think they start to cut out,
they start to erase some of the reasons
that people might engage.
Yeah you create a bedrock a foundation.
Right.
That you can build upon.
But I feel like
that was one initiative that has succeeded
in becoming a productive part of the national conversation
in no small part due to Andrew Yang.
I mean, he's the one who really.
Sure, yeah on the president of the stage
in the prominence and it's now being,
you know, reasonably considered.
Yeah.
In a way that a couple of years ago
people would have thought.
It was totally crazy.
Yeah right, I think what we're finding with policing
is that no response is actually gonna amount to safety
if people are insecure in their housing,
insecure in their work, insecure in,
you know how they feed themselves, right.
The system we have is, you know
can enact some brutality
on people who are perceived as committing harm,
but often enacts plenty of brutality
on people who aren't even perceived to be committing harms.
It just enacts brutality on them.
So I think that a real path is gonna have to be a mix
of us realizing that housing
and you know how people earn their living
and safety are not siloed,
you know, subjects matter, right.
And that we sort of have to engage these other forms
as we change our emergency responses.
And I think that what we're gonna find
is that for folks who were out there maybe selling drugs
or doing whatever kind of thing,
that we might see as harmful to our communities
that now we give them an out
and we're not, they don't they don't have an outright now.
Yeah.
And then what we're gonna find is that,
you know the person who has,
you know, bipolar disorder
and they're having an episode
or whatever's going on,
that if we can admit to ourselves,
that a cop showing up with a gun,
pointing their gun at that person and screaming at them,
doesn't actually help them.
It's not productive.
I mean I think another issue that will,
like if this becomes a thing that you'll have
to contend with is the difference between
conceptualization and execution.
Oh, for sure.
Like I'm thinking of child services,
for example, like the idea of child services
is very well-intentioned,
like to protect these kids,
but then it becomes abused and misused
and you know kids are getting yanked out of houses
that shouldn't get yanked out.
For sure.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like all sorts of stuff can go haywire
with this stuff.
Right?
The minute you start creating all of these bureaucracies.
But I actually think that it's the,
I think that it is our punitive inclination
that actually creates that right.
To me, that starts with,
I mean, that is a.
Well that's, I mean you could,
that traces all the way back to systemic racism.
Yeah.
In that regard.
Like, what is the intention
when you're knocking on that door?
And you're like, what are you expecting to see?
What is your bias going into that situation?
And what are the expectations or your quota
or whatever your boss is telling you?
For sure I mean, we've had,
you know, I think by and large,
you know people will find
that they'd much rather interact with like an EMT,
or a firefighter than a police officer,
but, you know I've heard from constituents,
that they feel like they've been assaulted by EMTs.
Right and so, you know, when
if an EMT is showing up to a scene
with the mentality of a police officer,
if a child protection worker is showing up
to that door, knocking on that door
with the mentality of a police officer
then you're gonna get sort
Right.
Of that punitive approach.
And if they know they're being dispatched
in lieu of police, though that could lead to that mentality.
I don't know that that's true.
Yeah.
I don't, I mean I'm not saying it's not true.
I just don't, I don't know for sure, right.
If that would be one of those assumptions.
That we would have to vet.
It's not a reason to not try, you know.
Right.
And it's one of those assumptions
that we would have to really vet, right.
And I mean, we're seeing that like,
look the violence interrupters,
and even before we had the cause there
the violence interrupters are pretty new.
Even before we had the violence interrupters
we had what's called GVI caseworkers.
This is group violence intervention, caseworkers.
You know, these guys they're not approaching,
you know, these are men and women
who are approaching their work with that sort of punitive.
Like, I gotta catch somebody in the act,
or I gotta wag my finger and and strict discipline,
or I gotta, you know this is not how they approach the work.
Right and so I think that it's possible
to create emergency responses that do that do by and large
have the intended outcome that you want right.
Now, you know anything that you don't
put a lot of care into a lot of investment into,
you know it's probably not gonna function very well.
So we're gonna have to make sure that
you know that these are not trends that come and go, right.
That you know, we tried that it worked
but the problem is not as prevalent now.
So we're gonna go ahead and give
all that money back to the police
if that's the outcome then.
Yeah I mean, we, I think we can pretty much count
on these cycles, continuing.
So I'm sitting down with the mayor tomorrow
and I know you guys don't see eye to eye on everything,
but you seem to have you seem to have a rapport.
Yeah.
You guys get along and everything.
What do you think? Like, what should I ask him?
Like, what would you like me to ask him?
What would you like me to hear his answer on?
You know, I think there,
you're gonna be better at this stuff than me,
but, you know there is one question
I feel like has gone really unanswered.
You know, there was this report by the UVM
that talked about the misuse
of less lethal rounds throughout the country.
And, but you know the start of their research
was here locally.
You know, things like, you know five-year-olds
that had nothing to do,
you know, them, their parents,
they weren't at the protest there.
You know, we had a firearm struck with a rubber bullet.
Scott hadn't received a skull fracture.
People who were hit with canisters,
you know, tear gas canisters, or you know,
flashband canisters,
right that you would have to
literally be aiming at their head
in order for that to really happen, journalists blinded.
Right, you don't have to ask them
the specifics about these cases.
'Cause these things are all gonna get litigated.
But, you know there was a time during the protest
after George Floyd was killed,
where, you know, yeah the crowds were upset
but the response from the police was excessive.
And I don't think that it could be
it could not be described by any reasonable person
who was there as anything other than excessive.
And if my memory serves me correctly,
it was two days of just excessive police force
on protestors before you
before the AutoZone went on fire.
Right and so to me, in my mind
that's two days where you could have.
But at that point there's no chance for deescalation.
When the AutoZone's on fire.
No, but you get two days before that.
Yeah.
You had two days before that
to address the situation
and to do something differently, right.
Instead of pushing these protesters,
creating a chaotic situation
in which non protestors felt welcomed
and then pushing the crowds back into the businesses
that aren't protected by you, right.
You push them, you literally push them back
into the neighborhood and into the businesses
that are not being protected by you right now.
And so, you know a lot of folks,
when they look at that report,
all the misuse, all the excessive violence
that happened during the protest,
I mean the state's lawsuit against the city of (indistinct)
against MPD for a pattern and practice of discrimination
is not because of what happened at George Floyd.
It's because of how police acted during the protests, right.
You know, there there's been this question
hanging of like, did the mayor and the chief
approve of this conduct, or was the chain of command broken
were rank and file officers going rogue.
And we don't know.
And I think that, I think that the mayor and the chief
have successfully avoided that question.
And, you know and quite honestly
they've reaped the benefits
of having no answer to that question.
Because if they maintained full control,
but also somehow didn't condone the conduct that occurred
well you know, that means that
they both made all the right decisions
and that they deserve to stay in control of the system.
Right, but there's no political benefit
in answering that question.
Sure, but I think that it's.
I think that there's a benefit to asking the question.
I you know, not that I'm saying
you have to ask them that question tomorrow
that'd be a hostile question to ask him,
I'm not gonna lie, but.
I gotta think about that.
But I do think that,
you know, I do think that
the answer to that question matters
not because it would hurt the mayor politically, right.
Or the chief or whatever, right.
I don't care about that.
But if, but every road to change
has to start with an acknowledgement.
Right and if we cannot have an acknowledgement
of what did and didn't occur,
then I don't know how we change.
Right you gotta have the reckoning.
Right.
Rights as a starting point.
That being said, though I feel like his position
on police reform, he's not willing to go as far
as you would like to go,
but he's fully acknowledging that the system is broken.
And is in significant need of dramatic repair.
While at the same time
not changing his response to protests
not changing his approach to that broken system.
You know, you can change the wording
on the use of force document,
which, you know had been rewritten pretty well
into just in 2016.
Right, you can do some of these things
that on paper look totally fine.
They looked like the right thing to do.
And then Brookline Center erupts.
But it takes.
And then just whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen.
Yeah dump gas on them, right.
That's if we're not,
you know you can say this system is deeply broken
but we're gonna surround the,
we're gonna surround all these buildings
with fences and barbed wire.
We're not gonna take the time to understand
why the crowd reacted the way it reacted.
And we're certainly not gonna admit
that we played any role in that.
Right, I think one of the most valuable things
about, you know the movie of a trial of the Chicago seven,
I brought it up earlier.
Is that, you know, and one of the values of reading
Kerner Commission, you know Macon Commission
the Commission on Race Relations,
the Illinois Commission On Race Relations from 1919.
One of the values that you get is that,
you know when you vet history,
a lot of the major riots once studied
are determined to have been started by the police.
Well, they I mean, that movie does a great job
of showing how that all came to be.
Right, and it's it's just history repeating itself
and repeating itself.
Right and so you say there's a problem
but then when you see the problem,
and we say like this, like this is the problem you go,
"No, this is a no, we're gonna keep doing it this way."
I think that, that is, you know
I think that it's caused problems
and after the death of Jamar Clark,
you know, that was sort of when this initial wave
that we're now re you know sort of remixing
this initial wave of reforms.
You know rewriting the use of force,
deescalation, all this stuff
that initial wave came came then, right.
We did all the stuff that we were supposed to do.
The city did, I wasn't an office,
but like the city did all the stuff that's supposed to do
about with regards to reform then.
Right.
And it was like,
here we go again.
Here we go again, right.
And we're rewriting the same.
We're taking the same documents that we rewrote in '16
and we're rewriting them now,
you know different mayor, different chief.
But and I think that that's the one thing
that I wish the mayor and the chief would understand
is that, you know admitting the failures
of this current system, asking the questions,
you know demanding some real change
is not a reflection of them 'cause they didn't build this.
But they are, you know sort of,
they have invested in the maintenance of it.
And I believe that they shouldn't be.
Yeah, no it's interesting.
I mean, it's a valid point.
It's certainly not,
I mean it's politically verboten let alone expedient right.
To admit that but I do think
like I'm a huge believer in the power of vulnerability.
And I think that level of honesty to like own,
you know do an inventory and actually own,
you know your side of the street and how that contributed
to what transpired just engender so much trust.
Ultimately you have to play the long game, right.
And if you're a politician,
you're always looking at the next election cycle.
I mean, but you don't have to though.
You can broaden that a little bit.
Michael Tubbs is 30, right I'm 31.
I was like, I was like oh that man is younger than me,
but like Michael Tubbs is 30.
Are you the youngest city council member.
Currently yeah.
I think that'll change next election cycle.
I think some good young folks are gonna win,
but like, but yeah I'm currently the youngest
and like, you know he rose to mayor
and I think in the city that he lived in
and I think it could be easy,
but I think it'd be a mistake to say like,
"Oh, this is a quick rise and fall."
Right guy's 30, he's got the rest of his life
to make an impact and like from everything
I've seen from him, he's gonna right.
I think that if I had to lose an election
because I advocated for a homeless shelter, for example
I could live with that.
If I had to lose an election
because I fought for more affordable housing
because I fought to create a system
that actually kept people safe, more safe than the one now.
Right, if I had to lose an election for those reasons,
like so be it, I can live with that forever.
I'll go back to paint murals, right.
You know, some of us are lucky enough
to be incredibly young in this job.
And if we have to lose an election
because we did the right thing,
in a moment that demanded that we do the right thing
and like, what's the real loss, right.
Well, yeah and the arc of history bends towards justice
like ultimately in you know that is playing the long game
because, you know you'll find yourself
in some other situation where you'll you know be fine.
Yeah.
Or get reelected
or whatever.
Right but what does it look like for you?
Are you in you in this for the,
like what's it look like 10 years from now?
Or are you in this game for good?
I you know, I think it's really important
that I play the role of I'm being asked to play
by my community right now.
I think, you know.
That's such a politician answer.
Yeah.
I mean, I'll put it this way.
I'm not thinking about that.
I'm just thinking about.
I mean, come on I came into this,
I got elected when I was 27
Yeah.
And I don't plan on doing this job till I'm 77.
I think that there's some real interesting things
that I've been able to create in the last three plus years.
And I think there's some real interesting things,
you know and I'm not just talking about public safety,
I'm talking about you know economic development.
I mean you know, for years people in North Minneapolis
have talked about, "Okay in the black community
"number one issue is access to capital."
And I created this fund that gave folks access to capital
and I'm seeing small businesses buy their building.
Right so now there's ownership within the community.
Right.
Set of landlords who live on the other side of town
Sometimes not even in this in the country, right.
And so, like I feel like
I'm really getting some things, right.
'Cause I'm willing to dig into the weeds
and I'm willing to respect,
you know, the expertise of some of our staff
and at the same time learn what they know
and try to push them as best as I can, right.
To do better on housing, to do better on this,
to do, to create these interesting things.
But I am a firm believer that,
you know when your time is up, it's better to,
you know sort of relinquish the mic
than to have it snatched from you.
And so, you know, I think that I don't want,
if I'm not looking around my community and saying,
you know who are all the brilliant people
that I know could do this job, right.
Who are all those people,
but they would never do it
'cause nobody ever told them
that they could be a city council member.
Responsibility.
Right like,
you know they would never do it
because nobody ever asked them, right.
You know, people always ask like
no offense to attorneys that you I'm know blood-related
to a bunch of people always ask
like the businessman or the attorney
to run for office, right.
They're not asking the artists
they're not I ask the youth work,
they're not asking, you know
the sanitation engineer who probably knows more about
problems in the city,
you know than than anybody else, right.
And so like, to me you know a part of my job
is to look around me look at my surroundings and say
"Who else could do this job and serve their community."
Whether they're older than me younger than me,
doesn't matter.
I think one of the things that we fail to do
and I guess the we here is I'm talking about
you know, young progressives and progressive, electives
and maybe electeds in general
is that we don't invest in people's leadership.
Right, we sort of just like allow leadership
to manifest in whatever way.
And then we you know, sort of hit the lottery
and you know, maybe this person.
Right.
Well, it's a lot easier
and a lot more fun to just criticize politics.
For sur, you know, I yeah for sure.
And that's fine you're gonna be criticized.
I hope whoever, I hope whatever,
you know young leaders that I'm investing in.
I hope that the one thing I can pass on to them
is to have really thick skin.
You, a lot of people have done this job badly.
Right a lot of people have caused harm
in these positions, right.
There's several council members,
even who like you know, you still see them around town
who like, you know they left office
'cause they took bribes, right.
A lot of people have caused harms in these positions,
have caused harm in these positions.
And so you better have the skin because you know,
your neighbors deserve at least that, you know?
So yeah, I don't know how long I'll do this.
I feel a lot of purpose in this work
and I feel pretty good at it.
I don't know that I enjoy it but I,
I mean you know look man
it feels like you got a pretty good grip on it
but I think you're in the right lane.
I'm sure you're itching to pick up a paint brush.
Yeah.
I don't know if you still do that in your free time
or if you have any free time.
I haven't had time lately.
If you were gonna,
if you were if you could do a mural right now,
what would you like?
What would that look like?
What would that mural be?
Oh man, right this second
I would probably wanna do something
that had nothing to do with any of this.
I probably wouldn't wanna just paint
like a huge like silver surfer,
like on the side of a building.
Just like.
Is that your guy?
I love silver surfer.
I think he's great.
One of my favorite favorite comics,
you know, but you know I'd probably wanna,
you know, I'm not even sure if
I'd have the energy to paint a mural right now, you know
it could be pretty physically.
I never quite realized how physically
involved mural making was,
but you know you build a scaffolding every day
and you're climbing this thing and climb down
and days are usually hot in Minnesota.
The days can be really trying to be pretty hot.
So I'm like, I don't even know
if I'd have the energy to paint mural right now.
It's not hot out.
It's not hot out right now.
That's funny 'cause I would've thought,
Oh, you'd have this perfectly grafted
like idea of this political,
politically charged mural that.
Oh man no.
You know, you'd wanna go paint down
at George flight's square.
You know what I would wanna do right now.
I, you know, I would
I probably could write a pretty good season of Fargo
right now.
Oh yeah.
(all laughing)
Like given everything.
Trust me it's hard to not visit here
and not think about I actually just watched that movie
like two weeks ago.
Have you seen the show at all?
Yeah.
The show is pretty good.
It's good
Yeah.
And The "Chris" though
the latest seasoned with Chris rock.
Oh yeah, that was really true.
Season two is probably still just like the best, but.
They're all so different.
Yeah, they're all really different.
But yeah.
But it's all the same vibe.
Yeah I wouldn't have to do it,
but yeah I could probably write a pretty good season
of "Fargo" right now.
All right, well good man. Good talking to you.
Yeah thank you.
How are you feel?
Feel all right.
You gotta get some food in you.
Yeah, I'm gonna go eat some more.
I think a couple of dates.
Couple dates, couple oranges yeah I know.
Cool man, I appreciate you talking to me
and best of luck winning your sales.
Yeah, thank you.
Thanks, peace.